let me ask you I'm going to ask one last
question before we get into the other
stuff but I want to ask you one last
question about do you like every comic
you run into no although are there ones
that I'm not gonna say full or stand-ups
just in general do other comics is just
kind of when you see them they just kind
of bother you mm-hmm you don't know why
no I do know why
oh you always know I usually know
exactly what is generally the reason why
you don't like a comment um as a person
when I run out as a stand-up not as
their material shut up
but the reason I there's the comics that
do bother me that that I don't like I
know why I don't like them is because I
feel like they're um they do they're not
genuine to me uh-huh
and they fake it with me yeah I'd rather
you not say hi then fake it to me yeah
and I feel a lot of guys that fake it to
me sometimes and I go I bet you think
I've talked to you about I can't name a
name but there's a guy that told another
person that okay he told Nikki Glaser
I've known this guy for [ __ ] 10 years
and Nikki he says to Nikki Glaser do you
know a drew Santino and she goes yeah I
love him I know I'm super well and then
this guy goes uh how was easy funny
what's it like what's going on okay and
she's like what yeah what's his tea is
he good what's his deal is he like a
Hollywood guy or some [ __ ] and she was
like what he means like is he like when
he's actor guys or is he [ __ ] she was
like nah yeah no he's good
I've I know this [ __ ] okay [ __ ]
we did TV together Wow yeah Wow fake
fake fake you're fake did you ever
confront him about it
[ __ ] no I don't want to see him yeah I
want to see you fight your fake you
tried to get you tried to dig something
out of somebody else behind my back yeah
you and by the way she was also like no
I love that dude that's my guy where she
she's we're homies yeah what he trying
to get some [ __ ] up right he wanted
her to talk [ __ ] with him because he
wanted to say some [ __ ] yeah I don't
play that game so now when I see him
once in a while I don't see him okay
that's all I'm saying I don't see you
anymore if you're gonna be like that to
mean fake I don't see that's I don't see
you anymore yeah I see yeah yeah there's
people that do that a lot
there's people that are phonies and they
do that [ __ ] a lot and I don't want to
do it anymore so there's a group of
women there are comics that don't like
me who a big group
Facebook group they're all friends like
three or four comedian female comments
New York or LA or New York okay and they
just don't the talk ship it might be on
my back I'll tell you why though k he's
because I played the Schomburg improv
many years ago me too and I had a MC who
was a local comic she's very funny name
I kept my saying I got it because I
wanna hide the war this war is kind of
subsiding I don't want to reignite it
okay and what she she shows up one day
and you know it's like I'm not when
Andrew and I'm not bragging but when
Andrew and I play a club it's not like
it's like people are coming on like
whatever we don't care who it is it's
people that are your fans right your
fans come these are this is your odd
like 99.9% I believe or just people that
are fans of mine yep
so this girl shows up who's a hosting
this usual local comic words wearing
this like Cinderella ballroom gown right
like a prom dress like a prom dress but
she would welcome say she had nothing
had to do with the way she was dressed
so she gone off and I go hey he just do
me a favor you think you're very funny
don't wear that cheek why I can wear
whatever I wanted I know it's my show
and it's weird yeah cuz you go out there
you set a tone right yeah and we got and
then she texted the manager and the
sound guy and everybody that was
poisonous Oh like I'm not hanging out
there after this she was Jose you
brought your feature though I brought a
feature which was this girl hates her to
that my future who was the feature kid
okay to prod okay right talked about it
with Jaden we have yeah so but one of
the her friends is now a regular at the
store right I can't tell you yeah she's
a regular at the store and I try go out
of my way to say hi to her why because I
don't I didn't hurt harm her in any kind
of way it was a friend that I [ __ ]
over but they're so tight that she's
committing to her you know it's like
it's like for me riot so I make it a
point to go hey how are you and she says
that's a true friend
Wow no it's not truth friend because
what she's doing though is that oh you
want to make it uncomfortable for me at
the store who's gonna win here right
[Music]